hello everyone and welcome to a truly
remarkable game from yesterday's julius
bear generation cup it's really been a
while since we've seen such attacking
mastery at work uh it is han smoke and
eemon vs lebon arunian and this game uh
you will not believe it i mean it's such
a
such a spectacular attacking game uh
that it it can you know serve as as just
a
you know a piece of admiration but also
as uh as an example of how to how to
properly attack but you'll see what i
mean by this it's a very short game uh
some 20 moves uh but i mean what a game
uh let's dive straight into it hans has
the white pieces and he opens with e4
and before we check out the game i would
just like to mention that gucash has
overtaken arjunary gaici as world number
18 in classical chess
by beating david tongiharo in the
spanish league and now arjun and gukesh
are
well gurkish is currently number 18 and
arjun irigase number 19
in
world classical chess so just a nice uh
bit of info for you to wield you know in
front of your friends at the bar or the
library so now let's continue the game
ponte e4 and levon goes for the sicilian
defense we have pawn to c5 knight f3 d6
and pawn to d4 so just nice sicilian
captures captures knight to f6 we have
knight to c3 and levon goes of course
for the knight of defense pawn to a6 and
now we always mention that there are
many moves you can play here like
literally any move here uh is a move and
you can play it uh but it what's
interesting is that hans uh chooses the
10th most popular move and that is
bishop to d3 probably something you
don't encounter very often uh but that's
not what's weird about this game uh so
here we have g6 levon prepares the
fiance to his dark square bishop hans
plays f3 okay very nicely done bishop to
g7 and now uh there are some games where
bishop to e3 was played as it makes
sense also uh just um
uh moving the knight to b3 was played
but here hans plays bishop back to e2
and this is very very odd uh of course
i'm sure hans has a very good reason why
he played this that's why he prepared it
for levon but what uh what a mysterious
move to play uh and okay uh and of
course it is as of this move we have a
completely new game which is uh for a
night of defense very very odd so here
at knight b37 by levon hans castles and
now pawn to b6 preparing the fiance to
the light square bishop as well we have
bishop to e3 and now bishop to b7 and
now hans just placed queen to d2 going
for the standard setup you want to put
the rook on d1 you want to maybe play
bishop h6 trade of the dark square
bishops and so on so one thing you will
not do is maybe push g4 h5 as you would
usually do against the athei and keto
setup as you have already castled king
side not queen side but okay let's see
what they have in store for us so queen
to c7 uh hans plays g4 and okay levon
says all right uh very interesting and
not not very impressed he goes knight to
e5 and now hans just plays g5 and okay
knight uh after d7 and now hans plays b3
he denies the c4 square for the knight
because it's a usual square you want to
play knight c4 you want to attack the
queen the bishop and then white has to
give up the light squad bishop so it's a
fairly standard stuff
and now what levon has to do is uh well
as hans just weakened the c3 square so
it makes sense to play rook c8 you put
pressure on the knight and then hans has
to deal with this or you castle or you
play knight to c6 however here levon
played ponte e6 and it's basically a
move that in this particular position
does nothing uh other than uh lose the
game so uh but it's not impressive that
it loses the game it's what's impressive
is how hunts uh does it uh and it's just
a like it's a remarkable attacking
artistry so here hans plays f4 and okay
you have to do something about the
knight but what do you do with the
knight and levon figures that if he goes
knight to c6 then hans will play knight
c to b5 and now the d6 pawn is extremely
weak it doesn't matter if you capture
the knight or not if even if you don't
capture it queen here uh just knight
captures on c6 and after bishop captures
you have to capture as the queen is
hanging so bishop captures no knight
captures on d6 with check you have to
move the king your king side is ruined
you're not castling this will be very
easily winning for white so your only
option here after knight c to b5 would
be to capture the knight but then this
knight captures on b5 again pressure c7
and d6 and once the queen moves knight
captures on d6 with the king of f8 and
now let's say rotated b1 and there's
just too much for black to deal with the
the monster knight here the rook never
entering the game uh the knight on d7 is
weak f5 is coming which will open up the
f file for the rook there's just no
surviving this so what levon tries is he
goes rook to c8 now he says all right
you capture on e5 i'm just going to
capture on c3 but han says nope uh he
plays knight uh
d to b5 now attacks the queen also
defends the knight in c3 and now levon
really has to capture there's no other
way otherwise the knight captures and d6
comes for free so a captures knight
captures and b5 attacks the queen and
the d6 spawn and now queen captures on
c2 levon offers a queen trade but now
knight captures on d6 forking the king
and the rook we have kinked the e7 and
now it's a beautiful beautiful position
hans has a truly spectacular attacking
sequence
installed so feel free to pause the
video here and try to figure out what
hans played while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on finding this uh
well just a brilliant brilliant attack
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is f captures on e5
and now you can see that uh there's
really nothing for black to do how are
you stopping rook captures on f7 uh
there's just no good way to do it you
you can play rook h2f8 to defend but
then of course hans will just capture
this rope with check and you will be
down too much material to continue the
game so what you could do is try to go
for a queen trade but then rook captures
on f7 and after king to d8 you will just
uh well
win back the queen and after let's say
there's really nothing to say i mean the
the bishop on b7 is hanging the bishop
and g7 is saying there's no move you can
make here if you try something like rook
to c2 to try and go for the bishops uh
you still just get obliterated knight
captures and b7 of course comes with
check then king c7 then rookie address
and g7 and okay you can capture here but
now just bishop to b5 and now if you
capture which is the only good move you
have let's say this that we can just
trade captures on d7 with czech real
captors bishop captures and hunts ends
up being up a full bishop
so after f captures an e5 levon says
all right i'm obviously not playing that
he tries knight captures on e5
but now hans has an even more uh
spectacular move and that is queen to b4
just outstanding just threatening all
sorts of nasty discoveries towards the
black king there's no way to stop this
the bishop also covers c5 so you can't
just put something on c5 even if you
wanted to play rook c5 okay i want to
give back some material queen captures
on b6 again the bishop is hanging the
rook is hanging there's nothing to play
here so after queen to b4 levon tries
queen captures on e2 but now hans has a
forced checkmate in uh however many
moves he wants but the cleanest one is
in three moves he plays knight to f5
delivers a double check from the knight
and the queen and he was in this
position on move 21 that levon arunian
resigned in the game as there is nothing
more to be done here uh if you go king
to d8 or king to e8 of course just queen
cap queen to e7 is checkmate as the
knight covers that square and if you go
to d7 of course it doesn't help just
queen d6 check king to e8 and now knight
captures on g7 is checkmate i mean what
what a truly spectacular attack
now like i said it's not all that uh
it's not all that impressive that hans
won this
what's impressive is that after levon
missed this uh and uh of course it's uh
pretty pretty a big thing to miss after
uh b3 was played and the c3 square was
weakened okay lemon plays the rook to c8
or he castles and okay white is still a
little bit better but that's pretty
standard when you play this line uh it's
it's of course very much playable uh but
after you know making this e6 move that
does literally nothing in this position
although it's a very standard idea uh
it's it's remarkable how hans just
completely obliterates uh lavon
you know just sweeps him off the board
it's true truly spectacular
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it very nicely done by hans
truly an attacking masterpiece i don't
think we've had uh uh such a game for
for a very very long time uh here are
the standings after three days of the
holy spirit generation cup if you guys
are interested uh there you have it the
the top eight to qualify for the main
event and those top eight are for the
moment magnus carlsen he retakes first
place even though he threw that game
against against hans so very very
impressive by him followed by arjun eric
ace and second liam pragananda uh
vincent kymer young shisht of duda hans
niemann and anish giri and uh the other
eight who will still have a chance as
today three more games are played
christopher you ross lavoie
vancouver uh david navarro levonna and
charity
so they will have to fight very hard not
all of them can make it to the main
event but uh you know some some will try
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh really just you know a
spectacular attacking masterpiece um you
know maybe we see more such games in the
future i would like to thank anta
bootygun is del marzia francis heir uh
la paz interior stuart matthews and
henry anumba for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the holy
spirit generation cup until it finishes
uh so thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your